[Music]
imagine you've been invited to a dinner
party as everyone is settling in you
notice that while the seats are the
perfect height for some of the guests
they are too high or too low for
others to make matters worse some guests
don't even have a seat at all this isn't
what you
expected like the dinner party research
regardless of the field may not benefit
everyone it is intended for in
practice the solution to this is equity
the practice of ensuring fairness and
Justice by considering the pre-existing
imbalances in research Equity is
important in the research content design
the findings whom the research helps and
within the researchers themselves how
does Equity apply to the dinner
party rather than merely providing a
seat at the table Equity would account
for everyone's needs and preferences
this includes not only having seats
appropriate for each guest but also
making sure that everyone is invited and
having different options of meals based
on each guest's diet in research Equity
is important for different
reasons first it prevents unintended yet
harmful consequences from occurring in
everyday
technology artificial intelligence for
instance plays an important role in many
fields such as education space
exploration and
Industry however it also has a history
of exhibiting gender and racial biases
in facial recognition and the evaluation
of candidates for jobs and Loans to
combat this issue in AI researchers
argue for the importance of building
upon existing principles and Frameworks
that have Equity at its Forefront such
as social justice feminism and critical
race studies
by designing training and refining
artificial intelligence applications of
equity can even overcome the flaws in
the systems to make Fair
decisions it is also crucial that new
discoveries accurately reflect the
general
population for decades the relationship
between high levels of HDL cholesterol
and a lower risk of heart disease has
been widely accepted and used in the
risk assessment for heart disease
however this link was confirmed only
among white
participants new research found that low
levels of HDL cholesterol were
associated with heart attacks among
white but not black
adults finally equity in research builds
trust between the scientific community
and the general
public take covid-19 vaccines for
example their development from the
initial designs to clinical trials and
their usage relied on the participation
of people from different nationalities
genders and
ages to make research more Equitable it
is first important to address the biases
within the field of
research while overall diversity drives
Innovation and is crucial in problem
solving researchers from
underrepresented backgrounds
disproportionately face barriers such as
failed tenure cases burnout and less
funding compared to their white
counterparts which may ultimately lead
them to leave Academia adopting an
approach of flexibility accommodations
and modifications can allow for a more
representative and inclusive research
Community it is also important to
incorporate equity in research design
and
process to prevent gender and sex
disparities in biomedical research as of
2014 the NIH required Grant applications
to report how their preclinical studies
balance the use of both male and female
cells and
animals Additionally the department of
Energy's office of science the largest
Federal sponsor of basic research in the
physical sciences is requiring
applicants to submit a plan for
promoting inclusive and Equitable
research alongside their research
proposals starting in the fiscal year
2023 while there is still work to be
done Equity is starting to change the
landscape of research as Equitable
practices are becoming more prevalent
across different areas of
study accounting for the different
populations present in our society is
just one example currently pulse lomets
provide a quick way to assess a
patient's lung Health but are more
likely to provide inaccurate oxygen
measurements for those with darker skin
the field of physics is tackling this
problem new Optical techniques are being
developed that can accurately measure
oxygen saturation levels
regardless of one's skin
tone in the social sciences and
Humanities archival activism is another
application of equity to ensure that
finds are as representative of as many
perspectives as
possible rather than only collecting
data from official public records or
other written accounts it considers
other sources within archives such as
oral histories works of art photographs
and everyday
objects
anthropologists have used this approach
to create a virtual journaling platform
to document the impact of the covid-19
pandemic in everyday
lives another Equitable practice is
collaboration between researchers and
their
participants in clinical research this
may include developing partnership
programs with clinical sites and
allowing communities to submit proposal
requests that address their specific
needs
Equity needs to be considered in every
aspect of research although there is no
on size fits-all approach to the topic
the general consensus is questioning the
status
quo with equity in mind everyone can
have their cake and eat it
[Music]
too
all